el objetivo de este vídeo es que ustedes
vean lo que en mi opinión es algo
sorprendente y una de las fotografías
más increíbles tomadas en la historia
esta imagen fue tomada por el telescopio
espacial hubble y lo que hicieron fue
apuntar este telescopio hacia esta
región de nuestro cielo nocturno y
recordemos que el telescopio espacial
hubble se encuentra en órbita de la
tierra y no tiene que preocuparse por
todas las cuestiones de contaminación
lumínica y otras interferencias que
tenemos aquí en la tierra por lo que
puede observar las cosas muy bien y
bueno hasta este espacio en relación con
la luna obviamente la luna se encuentra
en movimiento por lo que este lugar no
va a estar fijo cerca de la luna en el
momento en el que tomaron esta
fotografía la luna se encontraba cerca
de esta área que está en el recuadro
rojo y eligieron a esta ubicación porque
no se encuentran muchas estrellas
cercanas en esta parte si hubieran
estrellas cercanas aquí opacarían
cualquier otro objeto que se encontrara
detrás
ellas cosas más lejanas incluso galaxias
pero tengan en mente que todo lo que
vamos a ver se observó dentro de este
recuadro rojo y yo creo que tenemos la
imagen de la luna aquí para darnos una
idea de qué tan pequeña es esta área que
se observó de nuestro cielo nocturno y
de hecho esto se podría observar en
cualquier parte del cielo pero en otras
acciones podemos encontrarnos estrellas
cercanas cuya luz nos impediría ver lo
que se encuentra detrás pero las
galaxias se encuentran ahí ahí están
incluso cúmulos de galaxias o
supercúmulos de galaxias así que
recordando que todo lo que vamos a ver
ahorita se observó en esta área del
cielo prepárense para que su mente se
expanda y se sorprenda el propósito de
este vídeo es que ustedes se den cuenta
de la magnitud y enormidad de lo que
existe en nuestro universo esto de aquí
es lo que el telescopio espacial hubble
observó en ese recuadro del cielo todo
lo que están viendo aquí todo lo que les
estoy mostrando
está en ese recuadro y quiero aclararles
que algunas de estas cosas son estrellas
más o menos cercanas pero la mayoría de
estas cosas son galaxias ese es una
galaxia esta es otra galaxia aquí hay
otra galaxia aquí hay otra más y la
razón por la que les muestro esto es que
recordando lo que vimos en el vídeo
anterior vimos nuestro grupo local vimos
el super cúmulo de virgo también vimos
cúmulos de cúmulos y también vimos una
ilustración del universo observable pero
lo genial de esto es que es una
fotografía real estas son imágenes
reales de galaxias aquí hay otra aquí
hay otra y aquí hay otra arriba y
podemos seguir haciendo esto todo el
tiempo y recuerden que todo esto se
observó en apenas ese recuadrito de
cielo que vimos obviamente estas no son
todas las galaxias que existen en el
universo ni mucho menos son
a penas aquellas que podemos ver con el
telescopio espacial hubble seguramente
hay más galaxias todavía más lejos de
las que podemos ver aquí incluso
podríamos enfocarnos en un fragmento de
cielo como este y todavía observar hay
muchas más galaxias más lejanas y así
podríamos estar nos ampliando las
imágenes o acercando las si tuviéramos
instrumentos más potentes y yo los
invito a que entren al sitio web de nasa
para que vean todas las hermosas e
increíbles imágenes que tienen ahí
también hay bastantes imágenes en
wikipedia pero todas ellas son
increíbles aquí vemos otra galaxia y
aquí hay otra una más otra más sospecho
que incluso varias de estas cosas
podrían ser cúmulos de galaxias no
galaxias solitas aquí hay una galaxia
otra galaxia más y bueno aquí yo
resaltando las galaxias a diestra y
siniestra quizás nos haga perder la
dimensión de que cada una de estas cosas
que estoy señalando qué
la galaxia tiene cientos de miles de
millones de estrellas inclusive un píxel
de estas imágenes de galaxias tiene una
cantidad increíble de estrellas algo que
ni con toda la tecnología que pudiéramos
llegar a tener nos permitiría conocer
todo esto que existe ni en el tiempo de
vida de la humanidad mucho menos en el
tiempo de vida de una persona estas son
cosas enormes y hay una cantidad
infinita de ellas y aquí yo quería
compartir esto con ustedes y pues
simplemente admirarlo esto nos deja sin
aliento aquí hay otra galaxia otra
galaxia y puedo seguir haciendo esto
todo el tiempo incluso me siento mal
dibujando encima de la imagen porque
pues como que la arruina pero vean esta
es una galaxia hermosa hay muchas
galaxias por acá bien todo esto es
increíble y de hecho puede que este
vídeo sea el que tenga menos información
de los que he grabado pero sin duda yo
espero que sea él
desde más inspiración espero que lo
estén disfrutando vamos a terminar de
ver toda la imagen que parece que sigue
y sigue y nunca termina